la troupe a vu en révision est ce qu on
a vu des cousines russe d'isabelle
morini-bosc se présente à lewis était en
2012 elles ont fini deuxièmes
regardez les morinie
[Applaudissements]
aïe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est mon des liens c'est
l'eurovision c'est ça la chaussée à
chaud alors que nous continuons de jean
planté au milieu caennais a montré si
elles sont pas ce qu'elles sont
ravissantes à son milieu de tout ce que
vous voulez mais ça montre aussi à quel
point c'est très politique
oui et que la russie a beaucoup d'alliés
et votent pour la russie bien sûr
ironise 3 bien de le dire un petit sera
elle oui mais oui mais surtout sa foulée
de l'élimination marathon paulissen six
mois à poitiers initial tu veux que
terry un truc toi quoi ta gueule
pas loin qu'est ce qui se passe non j'ai
demandé ce n'était pas portraitiste
aussi il était brouille entre les deux
seins que je suis vous vous êtes qui
vous est le médiateur du blockhaus
conoco n'ose aller à les aimer cette
vanne nos collégiens mais joli on l'a
fait à chaque émission vous êtes
persuadé que c'est un tube avant on a vu
les coûts dans la rue mamata clash et
vous vous faites là chez vous allez
seront interne aux iraniens de montrer
son cul cul ah oui oui oui oui c'était
l'année dernière pendant la prestation
de l'australie
oui regardez quotidien spécialisé moyens
avant le vote contre regardez regardez
on comprend parce que mes parents on
comprend très bien regarder
[Rires]
tu vois
un mauvais rêve
le dax a reçoivent laissac shérif
[Musique]
je sens une date pour y additionnant je
regardais image est ce qu'on a vu
bernard montiel à l'eurovision distribué
non pas des points mais des points
soleil est ce qu on avait un candidat
faire l'eurovision en aluminium oui
c'est vrai c'est vers caceres douchka
c'est un ukrainien et feng shui
il a terminé deuxième en 2007 il est en
aluminium le gard dès lors il s'est fait
en ballet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce qu'on a dû stéphane bern
commenter l'eurovision avec moi même
temps qu'elle a dit et quatre minutes à
jouer un peu plus haut
2009c'est n'est qu'à 6 5 ans je sais pas
du tout rire du cfc la veste 101
dalmatiens les dvd des sandales version
achetée au rythme de la mode a ri gun
sur ces dernières promos les magnifiques
mais à mon avis c'est moi qui l'aï
donnée point il ya cinq minutes ils
l'attrapent dans la rue on s'écoute tu
vas donner les points mais ton tenue
mais moi ce que tu vois l'individu un
bel événement qu'elle ait insisté
cabanel est pas qu il est de la famille
bordenave était avec vous juniac on met
également au s'étaient régalés
franchement est-ce qu'on a on est on a
pleuré de rire avec julien on appelle
petites combines
non petit tour de magie vous allez voir
il va faire naître une flamme c'est son
côté patrick sébastien c'est son côté
grand cabaret week-end mais faut quand
même se sont un peu les chouchous de
nous croiser avec une très grande
utilisation du ventilateur comme jean
pierre foucault abeilles souffrent
tellement que jean-pierre de la voir un
autre ventilateur là ils sont pour lui
des jeux est ce que c'est votre dernier
mot sereine où il fait très bien c'est
un tapis à qu'il va remonter passer des
obstacles ce qui n'est pas sans rappeler
un termine qui reprend d'ailleurs
ça paye ça qui se trouve à ça qu'ils se
trouvent à ce qui veut dire en français
julien je ne sais pas genre et à ses
côtés julien moi je ne fais pas ce nom
il reste encore 18 chansons je suis est
déjà au bout du rouleau
[Applaudissements]